do
well being
past the appointed hour will call this
work session of the
house judiciary committee to order
and
perhaps represent horrigan would you
like to lead us in the pledge of
allegiance today
for the united states of america
to do the republic for which it stands
one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all thank
you this given being a work session do
we need to call a role today
no we don't really need to i have
everybody here to cheer mark just being
in attendance so
i think so thank you so the purpose of
uh today's meeting
is to address
uh
interim study we
sent
eight bills to interim study these were
bills that for one reason or another
we didn't feel that we were able to make
a recommendation on at the time
of our hearings
and so
we have really three alternatives today
and i've talked to the clerk
the clerk tells me that
our job is to make a recommendation on
each of these bills
as to whether we recommend for further
legislation
we recommend against further legislation
or
today if we're not prepared to do either
one of those two things to establish a
subcommittee and
to do a further study on the bill
so i thought we'd go through the bills
each of them today i think there's some
that we may be able to make a
recommendation on and there might be
some that we want to actually establish
subcommittees on
and i've handed out a sheet
which was prepared by
our researcher attorney for
for us which i really appreciate
which provides an explanation of each of
the bill or at least provides the
committee report that we submitted on
each of the bills that we sent to
interim study
and we'll just go through them in order
the first bill is house bill 124
adopting the uniform real property
transfer on death act uh mr chairman yes
just for clarification
if we decide today
that we're going to recommend uh
no further legislation
on bill
uh
can we is that can we take that as
dispositive action today
i believe that we could take that as
this positive action today
no
excuse me but we don't have a farm
okay do we need to have a quorum
mr chair
you're the lawyer
i would
i would i guess in my mind i would
consider this as the recommendation of
the work session
that would go
to
the full committee
at some time in september or
october
um
at which point we could just vote on
everything including if there are bills
where we have in fact created
a committee
but i think
like you might want to check with the
cleric but i think we've had a farm we
can't take an official vote okay
are we all in agreement with that
i agree with marjorie it just doesn't
feel right to yes thank you that's a
small number of people
yeah i'm fine with me
and in the fall of some of the members
who are absent they're going to be
absent in the fall then that'll give the
two caucus officers time to round up
replacements and so
okay
representative
just for clarification
i think that a subcommittee or the
working group would make the
recommendation to the full committee but
i think it's the full committee
some sort of quorum is needed to make
the final
recommendation also um the options for
recommend legislation not recommend
legislation or send it to the
subcommittee
for instance on this first bill
i think it perhaps
is something that would be referred for
future legislation but
i don't know that i would want to be
involved it seems like a rather in-depth
sort of work session that would be
needed along with
probably many other entities
you know giving their input on it so
it is there an option to
recommend for future legislation without
doing the study on it
okay just wanted to confirm that i
believe that there is and
with regard to
those two pieces of legislation
dealing with the transfer on death deeds
i've contacted
the attorneys that
that
came and spoke
at the hearing and
pointed out the issues with regard to
the bill
i am one of the attorneys for the tne
committee um
legislative committee and we're happy to
take both of those on we're looking at a
fall timeline just so you're aware thank
you
that's what he's going to say is they
they've agreed that
that they would come back in the fall
with a proposal for legislation so i
don't think there's a need for to create
a subcommittee to do that
representative and of course pointing
out the very the obvious some hp 124 is
appears to be
identical to sb243 except for the last
page which is uh
just like uh
which is uh
yeah and those aren't major policy
points on the last page obviously you
want to one subcommittee look at both of
those of course
stupefyingly obvious point but felt the
need to make it anyway
so
do
we want to do the formality of having
someone make a
motion that we recommend this for
further legislation
representative smith would you like to
do that
i would
make such a notion to recommend
it would be that on both bills house
bill 124 and
senate bill 243
so i guess i would rather since they
appear separately on
that's fine with me
is there a second to
represent smith's motion
seconded by representative sylvia and
i'd like to speak with for just
30 seconds you can
take all the time i would point out
to those people
on the committee and those people in the
audience
that
we're sympathetic to these bills we
think they need
a lot of work and we're not
in a position to do that or you know
incumbents um
who may or may not be elected in
november but as long as there are
covenants now can in fact file
legislation for the next
term
so that if um outside groups are working
on any of these
one of the things they might want to
think about is identifying potential
sponsors
of the
more carefully drafted
the legislation and actually filed them
starting in september so they don't have
to
they they will come back here for a
final vote but meanwhile on another
track
progress could be made on processing
then for consideration for the next term
and i
i hope my
secondary agrees with that
mr chair um
the filing dates for september are begin
on september 6th
and they end on september 16th
for new legislation
as any other discussion on the motion
and the motion is to
recommend house bill 124 for further
legislation
we need a roll call mr blair
i i don't think we do
since it's just a work session and you
know we're going to do is make a
recommendation to the full committee so
i think show hands or nodding of the
heads will be sufficient
okay
all those in
in favor raise your hand
all those opposed
right
house bill 248 relative to the judicial
retirement plan
i spoke with the sponsor this morning
representative lynn
and he
did not indicate that there he felt that
there was a continuing need for
legislation in the matter
and is there a second to that
exactly
second by representative wilper
any discussion
i um just
in terms of background
as you may recall
when it first came in there was a
discussion with regard to the need to do
a further actuarial study to determine
what the effect of the change would be
and the concern was the amount of money
that currently the state or the court
really is contributing towards the plan
and whether or not that was sustainable
i think they did the actuarial study and
found out that there wasn't it didn't
really make that much difference in
terms of the state's contribution so i
think it there wasn't a continuing
interest in pursuing
so we have a motion for on
house bill 248
that motion being not recommended for
further legislation
another discussion
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those opposed to tradition
house bill 379 relative to electronic
notice
hey
representative anders i know that when i
sent out an earlier email you indicated
that you might be interested in
studying that
yeah i'm very much interested in the
right to know law in new hampshire
and
i think we have to have a real in-depth
study
on everything
because if we make changes it has to
affect every agency everything in the
state of new hampshire schools i mean
everything we can't have two or three
different laws
and we have to make sure
that when we're done every citizen in
the state of new hampshire has a way of
receiving
notification
and
many don't have electronics
so we get we i think we have to figure
out what we really want to do because
we have to consider every person in the
state of new hampshire
representative
so i totally agree in terms of the right
to know act but this notice can go way
beyond that
because there's all kinds of notices
that are required in our state
and i'm not
quite sure even if we put something in
the right to no act except for the
purposes of this chapter
maybe we could avoid that but when you
start talking about like
foreclosures and and marriages
divorces whatever
there's all kinds of these notices that
have to be made public and
i i personally just don't think we're in
a place where we could possibly
avoid the intent of this is to avoid the
newspapers
and i and i don't see what
even being in a place where we could
seriously consider that so
i would just say like i guess i would
recommend future action but i wouldn't
want to try and do a study committee for
it
uh let me understand what you just said
you you would recommend further
legislative action or
well it's uh it's what representative
andrews said at some point
we're going to have to do this
right and it's a burdensome
right now on everybody to use newspapers
and
i'm about to campaign in barrington i
have no idea if there was even a
newspaper of general circulation within
barrington that i could go to to place
advertising
but the requirements are all over the
place
and and there is a lot of people who
would not
necessarily go to a website
or even think of going to a website to
look for a note to say of a hearing in
the courts
i don't know
so so yes eventually we need to be there
that's in the future
so maybe it's far future is what i'm
saying as opposed to the near future
and are you in favor of doing a study
committee a separate study committee or
are you saying
we need to we could recommend further
legislation without having a
study committee i see i don't see any
way that a study committee can come up
with any reasonable solution to this
now or even within the next i mean
several years
so no i would not favor a formal study
committee
okay
representative horrigan yes the
newspapers i mean i know
all our stage newspapers are mere shadow
of what they all are but i think they
still have their place people are going
to see these notices you might not be
know where to look for them on the
website and also the
newspaper every copy is at least in
theory exactly the same so there's never
any ambiguity about what the notice said
you could run into that with these
electronic notices people could
i could see like we had
a few of our friends who come in from
time to time i can imagine them like
forging a notice or
whatever so that's um
and also well
and the uh
newspapers that run the bulk of the
notices um they do maintain an
electronic archive which is uh available
though not necessarily for free like
which because it's mostly uh
i mean
most of them most of the ones most of
them are run by the union leader or to
lesser extent by the seacoast newspapers
and the valley news and the concord
monitor and those are all like
electronically archived so there still
is a
electronic copy they can look at and see
you can more confidence that that's uh
accurate than if you're just trying to
find the uh
you know the
government agencies website so i think
that's um
i think there's still a i think there's
still a place where they have a third
party that prints these princes notices
and actually
as for running ads in barrington there
is still uh the fosters daily democrat
and dover is still
in general circulation although actually
usually we get more news coverage about
the seacoast and the union leader than
in our what's obsessively our local
paper but
both of those still do run um
both of those still run a lot of notices
in fact that's probably one of their
major sources of revenue unfortunately
but so i would say uh i'd say the time
has not come to like eliminate the
requirement to print them in the
newspaper although
representative smith
thank you mr chair i think um in my
trying to process this i'm i'm
separating out
the importance of the issue
from the appropriateness
of
our
recommending action on a particular
piece of legislation
so that
i think the issue is very important but
if i were to choose how to vote and i
guess at some point i will on 379
i would say
no
uh
no recommend
not recommending uh
further legislation
because
i recognize the importance of the issue
but i don't think we're anywhere near
where we have an idea of what the
legislation should be
yes
representative wilbur so it sounds to me
like we have agreement on the situation
and the only question is do we want to
say yay or nay to
future legislation and so i would uh
willingly vote no for future legislation
because that'll be taken as like future
legislation right now
so i'd be i'd be happy to go on with no
recommend no future legislation
and if the chairs accepted that as a
motion i would say
uh representative wilbur having made the
motion
and representative smith having seconded
it
we have a motion that we
recommend
that we not recommend further
legislation on house bill 379
any other discussion
i tend to agree with that i think the
the i think at some point in time the
issue needs to be addressed but i don't
think we're at a point where we can make
any
any type of specific recommendation as
to what that should be at this point in
time so i
think the the
motion is appropriate
angular discussion
follows in favor of the motion please
raise your hand
all those opposed please raise your hand
the motion passes
7-0
house bill 1181
allowing a biological father of an
unborn child to petition a court for an
injunction prohibiting the biological
mother from having an abortion
representative i know in our earlier
emails you indicated that you might be
amenable to having a study committee
so mr chairman i think this is an
important issue and it's one that does
need to be addressed and
both save lives and enhance the quality
of life for a lot of fathers
even mothers
so yeah i'd be i'd be willing to chair a
subcommittee on it
if the other members don't feel like
there's
any real benefit or
that the issue is too difficult and i'll
just work with the
crime sponsor and we'll come back with
new legislation next year
representative smith
thank you mr chair while i completely
respect
my
colleagues interest in the issue
um
i think that
he
just made a
very valid point and that is
in this particular situation
what might be the most appropriate
is to
actually work with those people
committed to this issue
to draft legislation
to come before the future
legislature the legislature
elected in november
and
therefore following the reasoning that
we've tried to apply up until now that
as far as
our
current committee
it would be to
not recommend
further
legislation
which clearly
only means
that
the responsibility for pursuing the
issue
would fall with the
the to those
clearly committed
to its future
any other
comments
represented sylvia
i think this is uh
an interesting and difficult question
um
one of the things looking at the bill
and starting out is this could be a
petition to
the family division
of
the court
which is
um
i guess i have to avoid
certain words
let's say
not functioning at an optimal level
and of course it would be questions of
who is the father
so i i think it
it needs further legislation certainly
needs study
i don't know that the committee will
come to any solid ground on this
so um i i
assume that uh the the sponsors will
come back with another version
and
so i would i would lean towards uh
indeed sporting future legislation
you would i'm sorry
i would support a recommendation of
uh
recommending further legislation
i don't know if the study committee will
produce
it could i i i
not entirely certain i would want to be
on it but i i
i would
certainly
want to accord
uh
those interested in uh pursuing it
do
representative walker can i before i
call on you to comment
uh do you know of anyone else who would
like to serve on the committee with you
uh no mr chairman uh
not this is up to the other members of
the committee if any of them if
if if if the study committee is going to
be me
then we don't need a study committee
so that's my answer
but no one has uh stepped up to say oh
i'd like to do on that with you as i did
for representative mclean
so i guess this is uh you know sort of
the way i feel about it is
is
as an option here today if i have a
committee member who says you know i
would like to take the time to study it
i'd probably want to submit the to
support my committee member
regardless of
the feeling at the time and let them do
their study and then come back with a
recommendation
i guess the question is
do i do that if there's only
one person who's going to be doing the
study and i guess
we could do that basically
just defer the question for now until we
have our further meeting of the
committee and allow you to come back
with making some recommendation at the
time
does that make sense to you
representative smith
well i hear what you're saying and
i believe as representative wolfer who
knows
despite our
long-held disagreement on this issue we
have been
very supportive of each other in terms
of acting responsibly as legislators
if representative wooper is going to
look at this issue himself and with
others who share his
commitment to
developing appropriate legislation
i think that happens outside of the
current judiciary committee
and
what we would see probably before
we meet again to finalize the decisions
that
or the recommendations that we make
today
is the likelihood of draft legislation
having been filed with ols
so
i don't think we need
i don't think it's even necessarily
appropriate to have
to say that we are creating an interim
study committee
um it reminds me of what
uh
john kennedy said when he
had a gathering with nobel prize
winners and um
he said he thought this was the most
incredible gathering of intelligence
since
thomas jefferson had dined alone
and in this case
representative welker can dine alone
figure out what to do and then do it
so mr chairman i pretty much have to
agree that's a study committee of one
makes no sense to me at all
so are you supporting a recommendation
of no further legislation
i would support it yes
and and who would like to make that
motion
if in fact you're looking for such
emotion um and of respect for all of my
colleagues i would make that motion
and seconded by
representative lorenzo
representative sylvia
just one
observation
um and i although no on this
recommendation with all due respect
i think that
a study committee
would benefit
from having
parties that are not in support of this
idea and see if there is any sort of
middle ground that might be reached
obviously you know this is very
abortion is a divisive issue
the right of the parents um
is
perhaps a little less divisive and
perhaps
um there is more
possibility of a middle ground but
that's
just my opinion
but you have just indicated i thought
that you didn't want to serve on such a
a sub committee
and
i haven't seen anyone else who has
chosen to be here today who has
indicated
i'm not aware of anyone who has
contacted either the chair or the
obvious um
leader on this committee who would
support this
and so
um
with all due respect um
uh i think you know you're either
interaction
and you can't be both although as
you and i know we frequently try to have
conversations about why
individuals who don't believe in
government at all
nonetheless believe that they have a
right to control
a woman's body but we can have that
discussion another time
so it seems to me that you either have
to step up to the plate and say yes you
work with representative welper
and uh try to
produce something that the full
committee would accept
um uh
when we have no obligation
as a committee to write legislation
um either that or you have to say it's
an important issue and representative
wealth is going to pursue it on its own
not worry about what you might
say subsequently to someone who will ask
you well so how come you didn't
advocate for this
thank you
yes representative wilpert
so just to
there's no requirement that we have
unanimous votes
right
but there
uh there is it seems to me that there's
another alternative here and that is i
don't think we're under any obligation
today to come up with a final
recommendation
so i don't think
we have to come up with a recommendation
today one way or the other or even
create a study committee today
if the full committee is going to be
coming back again so
one of our options today it seems to me
is that
we can
agree that we're going to not going to
take any action on this today
and then when we come back for a full
committee
decide what we want to do
representative wolfer is that an
indication you want to speak no it's
insane it's interesting
so it's an interesting idea
mr chairman it sounds to me like
uh
so we're gonna we'll just not do
anything today we'll kick that can down
the road and when we come back together
if there's legislation already drafted
then we'll recommend
that well we'll decide whether or not to
recommend that legislation act
i don't know well the the thing is that
and the way i'm the the reason i suggest
that today is that
we have seven people here today
i don't know if there were other people
who might volunteer
on our committee to be on a subcommittee
if if we had the full committee here i
don't know if representative notter
might
agree to be on the subcommittee or
representative merner be on a
subcommittee or
representative chase be on the
subcommittee so long and short is
i guess the question is should the seven
of us decide to make that recommendation
today when we don't necessarily have to
make that recommendation
this chair i would be happy to withdraw
my motion and leave a blank slate
uh here tabula rosso for us
on this phil i don't know what in fact
i i can speak for
members of the committee
and
say
that
10 members of the committee
have been asked on three or four
different occasions do you have any
interest
in serving on
any
interim study committees of any of these
bills that are before the judiciary
committee
and um i have had responses from every
one of those people
and only one person has responded saying
yes uh she has interest in serving on
one interim study committee and it's not
this
i know i don't know about the majority
but
i can speak i
believe with
authority
that
of the
seven
democrats who are not here not one of
them wants to serve on any of these
representatives yes i would be reluctant
to serve in this subcommittee because
i'm just so
viscerally horrified by the basic aim of
it i'm not sure whether
um
a man even if it is the father forcing a
woman to give birth against their will
is uh that's something very hard for me
to accept under any circumstances even
if there's all this due process in here
but the problem i mean
and bill's probably on aside from that
the bill's probably unnecessary and i
haven't looked into the law relating to
paternity testing but i'm sure there's
uh
we've been doing paternity testing even
before we knew about dna so it's
probably like a large body of law and
somebody
somebody might want to look into us
looking
look into that before we meet in
september i don't recall that coming up
at all at the uh at the at the hearing
or during our executive session on it
but there's um
but i don't know where that would meet
the concerns of the sponsors of this
since you know
since uh you know paternity testing is a
long-established medical procedure and
maybe
maybe there's improvements made to the
laws or the regulations regulating that
but that's not really
probably the intent of this bill so i
would
yes i would i would certainly like i
would certainly not want to serve on a
subcommittee related to this issue even
though it's a very very hot topic which
is going to be
vigorously uh debated next year here in
concord and and
and every other legislative body so
that's that's where i'm coming from on
this one
else
personally i just prefer
not making a recommendation today with
the seven of us and waiting for the full
committee to do that mr chair would it
be appropriate for me to withdraw my
promotion and uh to see if in fact uh
representative lorenzo would withdraw
the second
i would like to withdraw the second
place thank you very much
and i guess i would
uh just
move that we make no recommendation at
this time and wait till we have our full
committee session before we do so
is there a second to that
representative lorenzo we can second
that thank you
any other discussion
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those opposed
yeah so
house bill 1389
establishing a superior court
land use review docket
i did talk to the sponsor again
who was representative lynn this morning
he
he's sort of
i i i guess the best way to describe is
sort of ambivalent about it and that
uh he sees the potential value of a land
use docket
on the other side
he sees that
the discussion that we all had and that
was
if you're going to give the court
another judge and or 500 000
is that actually the best use of the fun
so
he was sort of
up in the air as to
whether he
he didn't feel strongly one way or
another as to what the committee did
today i guess is the best way to say it
representative smith
thank you mr chair um i know this is a
work session i don't know if there
happens to be anybody sitting in the
room
who uh might be in a position to tell us
what in fact
the
judicial branch
would
like us to do
but
we are now entering a budget year
the judicial branch should be well into
the process
of
constructing what it is going to submit
to the governor
and
uh that would be
the
ideal place
if the judicial branch was seriously
considering a change in its structure
and at the same time
a need for additional funds to carry out
that purpose and so um
that being the case i i think
um again
to say that we are not recommending
further
uh
action does not mean
that we're making a decision on
the merits or the cost
of this but that it's just not
appropriate at this time for this
committee
to take further action
represent do you want to address that
i've represented that attorney excuse
get demoted
i won't say what direction that is
um good morning thank you my name is
richard head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch
as
in recognition of the comments that were
made during the extent during the
executive session i did send a follow-up
letter
to the committee
and noted that the judicial branch
supports the policy behind this bill um
of
improving the the speed at which um
appeals from land use boards are
are conducted in the in the judicial
branch
uh we do support the legislation for
that reason
and i think similar to
and i can't say specifically
it's up to the chief justice obviously
as to whether or not there's going to be
a recommendation for the position in the
in the recommended budget
um but he does support this legislation
does support the idea behind it
i think similar to
one of the earlier bills where there may
be an expectation that something would
be brought forward next session
it would be i think a helpful
recommendation if the policy behind this
bill of expediting the the reviews um by
the judicial branch of land use appeals
uh is
uh is warranted i think a positive
recommendation of future legislation
would be helpful towards moving that
along without
saying that that you know
you don't need to study it further but
it i think it would be a positive policy
recommendation in that regard if if
there was a recommendation of future
legislation um i think that if it was a
negative vote i think that would
perhaps be
be reviewed negatively if we were to try
to bring that position forward so i
think a positive recommendation leaves
at least that door open a little bit
better for for the judicial branch
representative smith
thank you very much
for that information it's very helpful
um can you tell me if um
the
judicial branch
went through a process in which they
decided that given um
the caseload that they have across
disparate areas
and the um
the potential shortage of
judges and support staff
in the entire
judicial branch
that they made a calculated decision
that it is land use
that should be brought to the top
of the list in order to make sure that
land use
issues moved at a rate
more rapidly than
all the others so thank you for the
question i think the
probably the short answer is
no in that sense but we have heard
through through
multiple pieces of legislation
that this is an area of priority for the
legislative branch um so we saw it in
senate bill 400 we saw it in this bill
in the what was interesting in the
in remember which bill senate bill 400
ultimately ended up in because it was
tacked on to another bill and then
i think it was actually the bill on the
parking garage um
the issue that bill had specific
deadlines built into it for appeals from
land use boards and it's my
understanding from the comments that
were made is that representative osborne
had
asked that that be pulled out in light
of this very meeting here today
to discuss the land use boards
so
i do think there is a
a strong
legislative
support for this so i think we're
reacting to that as opposed to saying
you know all of the areas of law that
the that the
superior court reviews or the judicial
branch reviews you know which ones
should be given higher priority you know
there are a number of them that i think
we
there might be agreement on i think
family division might be one of them
but i do think
land use is
[Music]
an area in which there is strong support
for
um for having a faster review in large
part because the nature of those
projects
tend to be very time sensitive
do you remember i don't have the omnibus
uh
compromise bill in front of me do you
have remember which one of the sections
of the many sections of that
so
no is the short answer um it was because
the dhhs large bill got pulled into that
also um i don't remember and i don't
have in front of me that that that bill
um most of senate bill 400 stayed in the
final version um but the specific
sections that dealt with the deadlines
for the superior court were pulled in
the comment was this bill
thank you could i follow up
so at the time when
are you saying that at the time that the
legislature was making final uh taking
final dispositive action on this
that section
was removed
that's correct and my interpretation and
i'm only speaking from an audience
member's perspective the comment was
made
that
the issue of timing and deadlines
was
would be
would be considered as part of today's
session on this particular bill thank
you just if i could just follow up one
more and when you say that there's
strong
legislative support for that
you noted um the majority leader and we
certainly know you know the major role
that he has played in this
in this current term
um
can you help me understand who else was
since there are 400 members
who else shares that of i guess
let's see that favorite was
representative lynn on this one too
yes um so those two uh
yes so can you tell me who else in
addition to
uh
former justice lynn and
uh majority leader osborne
were part of this
cohort that legislative cohort that took
a major position on this
so noah's the short answer it was a
comment made during the
um committee of conference by one of the
republican members of that of that
committee
um that i'm that i'm referring to
obviously i wouldn't speak for the from
any other members other than just
the comment i specifically heard
one of the other aspects of this i think
is you know we also have the
uh separate administrative docket that
that is an option that
um
provides excuse me some relief for a
subset of appeals
um
they deal with residential or
residential related appeals so the the
data pellet board is an option but it
doesn't cover all types of land use
decisions
um so but that i think is further
evidence of at least a legislative
interest in having a more rapid review
of of these types of projects or these
types of appeals
thank you that's very helpful and of
course in that particular case we did
agree
with the creation of a special board we
now had not quite
two years i guess of
experience there relatively few cases
but cases that where we've demonstrated
the value of that particular board so
that the legislature did commit to
specific action there whereas
they chose so far not to commit here but
your comments have been very helpful and
i appreciate your candor
um
which
since not one of us including the former
judge sitting here
would believe that
and that we have
a
full grasp on the complexities of what
the judicial branch is juggling right
now
so thank you thank you
i guess if i could
follow up on that
as
it's not as if the court system is just
ticking along
smoothly at this you're doing great okay
so
has the court system
provided at some point in time a list of
what its priorities might be
if you have a half a million dollars of
funding
as opposed to to fix the current
problems as opposed to
trying to create a brand new court
so so a fair question um
[Music]
one i don't think we're creating a brand
new court we're creating a subgroup
within the existing court that would be
a particular docket similar to what we
have for commercial disputes
we do have in process more directly to
your question um a
a time study
with the national center of state courts
that data is expected to be uh complete
that report is expected to be completed
by mid-summer
i think that will also be helpful
certainly for the judicial branch in
identifying areas of priority
um and and would be i think constructive
to the to the legislative branch also
so i think some of from our perspective
we are waiting for
that data to come in in a final form so
that we can identify where there are
um
specific areas of of need
so i do think you know there is a a
larger
discussion that's going to be had in the
context of the budget where those
priorities are are going to be
identified and the i think the chief
justice will be
will be doing that work over the summer
with some of this data
i'm only suggesting that one of those
areas i think of evaluation and
examination will be
land use appeals
and
i just want to follow up because i think
that that is the issue that i have with
this particular bill and that is
we're not handling our criminal cases in
the superior court with efficiency right
now we're backed up
and
i might disagree a little bit with that
but well
okay look at the numbers you know i
think that's all you have to look at and
and
i guess the reason is what are the
causal relationships there i mean
between the pandemic and the the
shortages in the uh public defenders
group um
but i i
i get what you're saying also
right it
it's anybody's fault but the court
systems no i i and so
i'm just saying there's it's not just
the court system and not just resources
within the court system right but it
needs to be fixed
whether who whoever caused it whatever
the cause might be it needs to be fixed
and
we got small claims cases
the constant complaints about small
claims cases not being hurt not being
timely heard
and and giving the lowest priority in
the system and so
i'm just wondering you know if you're
going to focus funds are you going to
focus funds to fix
the current system you know let's so so
thank you for the question and and you
know i throughout
this session in some last session i'm
relatively new in this position
i have identified especially in the
circuit court significant resource
limitations that the court has
both in terms of clerk's office staffing
and also judicial resources
and i say that in the context of
legislation
that is adding to the burden of the
circuit court
so as
you know additional legislation
gets added
i think the ripple effects also have to
be considered by the by the legislature
in terms of
in a similar to the conversation we're
having about the land use docket once
you prioritize one thing
you are necessarily with a limited with
a fixed amount of resources going to
cause some other
ripple effect through the system so if
we for example
move something from superior court to
circuit court or we increase the number
of hearings on a particular area and
circuit court
things that don't have statutory
deadlines or don't have constitutional
deadlines such as small claims
are inevitably going to be pushed
down stream
unless there are additional resources
put into the system
and that's absolutely true and
and
and i do think this time study is going
to help provide data on where
we have
resource limitations that are causing
that type of of impact in terms of the
length of time cases are taken are being
taken to or take to handle
representative wolper
thank you mr chairman thank you for uh
giving us the information that you have
i want to
follow what representative smith
mentioned and that is we just recently
created the housing
appeals board
and the intent of that is
i think identical to what the intent of
this project this
suggestion for
docket is
i think we'd be uh better served
to just let the housing appeals board
work for another year or two
before we even
consider uh a docket in the courts
and the comp necess the complications
that come with that
so i would say we should just not pursue
this
representative smith
uh again thank you for the information
it helps us a lot to get that that kind
of information
and i hear what representative uh
welfare has said and i agree completely
but because of the information you've
given us and saying that there is a
study from an uh
quite a reputable external
group that where you expect to get the
results by
mid-summer
we're hopeful in august uh then i wonder
if um
it would be appropriate for us to take
the same action here that we did on
the previous bill and not reach any
decision today understanding that it is
conceivable
that when that report comes back in mid
august assuming that it's not
confidential and can be shared with um
with this body
we might have um
just that piece of additional
information that could help us make a
better informed decision
when we act
in the fall
i have no
particular objections or concerns about
about taking that approach either i
would
just add one other comment that
you know if if the recommendation is to
not
ultimately whether today or be down the
road to not recommend further
legislation on this bill
i would have some concern if there were
legislation next session to
statutorily impose new deadlines on the
court without additional resources
similar to the conversation we've been
having so similar to what we saw in the
senate bill this session
you know essentially creating very tight
deadlines on court review of land use
dockets without relief such as this
creates the problems that we see
that that the chair was talking about
where okay something is going to get
pushed down downstream
um so
i think that's the that's the sort of
balance in terms of of the
recommendation and i think the
recommendation then if it's a no further
legislation on this type would be i
would like the message i would hope
would be
you know we have this new
docket through the other process through
the administrator process let that take
its course rather than starting to
impose narrow deadlines on the court
without additional resources
representative smith again thank you
i want to point out that
something that i alluded to earlier and
that is that we are about to that we are
well into the next budget cycle
and
one very
telling
piece of information would be if um
the court
is suggesting
to the governor
that uh
this particular docket
uh
rises
to the top tier of importance and
therefore
we are asking for
x hundred thousand dollars in the budget
that would be starting um
not quite a year from now um
in july
first 2023
um to carry out such
purpose or perhaps as the chair has
indicated
that the court might
wane
a lot of very difficult choices and we
understand that difficult choices might
in fact
indicate
that if the port were to have access to
additional funds it would bother those
funds or who choose to have those funds
go to a b or c
an absent from that list might be
a land use
docket so that we have happening in the
next few months a number of activities
judicial branch submitting its budget
to governor
and the study committee coming back
there's this study group coming back in
august all of that would help inform
this committee as to what we might want
to say
in uh
and something that we're
required to do by
november 1st is it
yes so
those that calendar makes it possible
again for us to have
better
information than we have today i think
those are all fair points thank you for
the for the comments
so were you making a motion that we not
make a recommendation
move by representative smith second by
representing silvia that we make no
recommendation at this time
any other discussion
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those opposed
so we'll make no recommendation
i think that's the right decision
next one is house bill 1435 relative to
the right of a victim of domestic
violence to have a support person
present when testifying or being deposed
one thing i would point out is that i
understand the governor is
reconstituting the domestic violence
task force
and
and it
we
might want to defer to them as to what
they believe the needs are
as opposed to us making a specific
recommendation
mike uh representative sylvia
so
i
briefly looked at the bill which is very
short in fact it's probably shorter than
the committee report
but it has
i think
problems that are
insurmountable in its current
state uh so i would certainly
propose
not recommending
further
legislation and
uh let's
and
see how the uh
task force uh
suggests solving the problems
is that a motion
yes it is and is there a second to that
motion
that we
recommend no further legislation
no
future recommendations
any other discussion
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those opposed
and i think that was eight zero
welcome representative langley
thank you
senate bill 243
transfer on jeff deeds
and if we were to take similar actions
to house bill 124 we might recommend
further legislation i don't know if
somebody wants to make that motion
representative smith moves
that we recommend further legislation
and
is there seconded
representative sylvia seconds
any other discussion
seeing none
of representative wolf i i suppose for
the benefit of representative langley
who wasn't here for the first discussion
she may want to just hear a few words
before we ask her to vote
representative we actually have a
representative here from a group who is
working on proposed legislation and it's
the same group who came to testify at
our hearing
and explained all the problems with the
current bill
and they're working on coming up with a
proposal for legislation that would
that would work because the base i think
people believe that the basic idea was
good at just the way the legislation was
constructed it didn't work well for new
hampshire
and so
we've recommended the other bill which
is very similar for further legislation
and i think that's the proposal for this
one as well
okay
they're extremely similar i think the
first three pages are identical it's
just the
page four was different but the other
hand are uncertainty about passing you
know one of them was not strictly
because of what was on page four so
okay so we have a motion pending any
other discussion
always in favor raise your hand
all those opposed originally
again eight zero
and finally senate bill 296 relative to
complaint procedures and cases before
the commission for human rights
and representative mclean has indicated
that he would like to do a study
committee
and i think representative wolpers
indicated that he'd like to be on the
committee and representative simpson
that's representative smith
did was representative smith simpson no
just representative smith
oh and representative lorenzo
mclean
smith d lorenzo wolfer
any others
did represent simpsons indicate that she
wanted to be on the committee do you
know
well i can we can double check with her
all i can say is that
she told me no but she might have
changed her mind because okay you're
such a persuasive neither no
and i'd be happy to double check with
her when it's time
so are we in favor of having a study
committee
yes
i take it that means we're going to
postpone the decision today won't be any
decision today we'll just make a motion
to appoint i guess a motion to appoint a
committee
and
i like that
mr chairman my understanding i see you
have a calendar in front of you is that
um representative mclean has in fact put
in the calendar
a meeting of
a work group
optimistically he put in the calendar
a meeting of a work group for
next wednesday the 15th at 1 00 pm
and he he did that because he wanted to
make sure that as much notice as
possible
was given to the myriad people in the
community who would be interested in
helping
shape the work
of this um
of this subcommittee
okay
somebody like to make a motion that we
form a
committee or do we need to have a motion
i guess
i guess that we should
representative wilper so i move we
appoint a study committee
seconded by
i i would be happy the second uh just
one i would have the average second
and
other discussion
all those in favor please raise your
hand
all those opposed
raise your hand and mr chairman i
correct that um
in as the event has now taken place that
we have asked for such a study committee
that
you had indicated that if such a
committee were to be formed that you
would ask representative mclean to chair
it
yes
that's correct
he i would direct him to chair of the
committee
good
and i will sort of i and i'll make an
effort to participate ex officials
well of course as a member of
the judiciary committee i don't think it
has to be ex-official okay
any member of the judiciary committee is
free to
come it's just if there are poor people
all the sessions are public sessions
right
and any member of the committee can
certainly
attend but technically what
you know they don't have the status of
full subcommittee members although it
would be really good for us to have
another one
so there would be five instead of four
then then i'll sit in on the committee
if that's okay with everyone
okay i think
that
concludes our
work today
is there any other business we need to
address
i know just like to note that all our
votes were unanimous
today that's much appreciated it's a
great committee working together
and then mr chair as a full committee
we would
we have only one
one uh
subcommittee that we've established
whatever you would call it for a group
subcommittee to i don't know
but that the full
would meet then sometime in the fall in
order to confirm
or to vote on
our suggestions
that we made today plus suggestion
coming from the one subcommittee yep
that's my understanding
that's what we discussed earlier on and
i think that's the intent
right
okay
hope you all have a good summer
mr chair yes stay in um obviously i
apologize i made a mistake i obviously
thought the meeting was starting at 10.
so my apologies to the committee
no apology necessary
thank you for coming
some of us would say that this mistake
was on the part of the chair for
scheduling it at nine instead of ten
i would second that
i left the house guest sleeping
yeah
i had to check my calendar three times
i'd open the official calendar
yeah
well i like to get other things done
during the day
you